quelqu'un qui reprend pleinement les
principes fondateurs sur lesquelles
repose cette organisation notamment la
peine le 15 septembre nous avons tous
été témoins des résultats de la vision
de la persévérance du président trump
israël les émirats arabes unis et le bas
et rennes se sont retrouvés pour signer
les accords historiques amram ouvrant
une nouvelle ère de paix au moyen-orient
cette nouvelle ère offre à la région et
à sa population le premier nouvel espoir
de paix depuis une génération
les états unis convie les palestiniens à
saisir l'occasion qui leur est donnée de
travailler dans cet esprit au début de
ce mois le président trump a aussi
normaliser les relations économiques
entre la serbie et le kosovo une percée
sur la voie de la réconciliation pour
les peuples des balkans une région qui
n'a que trop subi de bain de sang en
corée du nord
la vision en phase ii du président a
permis de progresser le président trump
est le premier président américain à
avoir rencontré les dirigeants
nord-coréens les américains détenus en
corée du nord ont été restitués à leur
pays
il n'a plus d'essais nucléaires plus de
tirs de missiles longue portée
là les tensions considérablement diminué
dans la région
les perspectives de perspectives de paix
dans la péninsule existe et il est clair
que lorsque le président trump prend la
parole et dirigeants du monde lui
prêtent l'oreille
en 2018 le président trump utilisait son
pouvoir de conviction pour me lasser
mettre en garde le régime d'assad et ses
partenaires leur demandant de cesser les
attaques sur la province d'idlib
ils ont eu la sagesse de l'entendre ce
qui a permis d'épargner des milliers de
vies en seriez alors que je suis devant
vous aujourd'hui
les pourparlers de paix est dirigée par
les états unis entre avec l'afghanistan
sont en cours les femmes occupent à
présent des postes dans le cadre du
processus de paix en afghanistan le
processus
le président trump est convaincu qu'il
existe un lien
r entre les femmes occupant des postes
de pouvoir et un avenir plus radieux un
avenir meilleur pour le peuple afghan
et pourtant une fois encore le président
a montré les qualités nécessaires pour
ramener des adversaires de longue date
un vrai pour la paix grâce à son
leadership audacieux à sa détermination
cible et a une capacité inégalée de
président de sortir du statu quo pour
conclure des accords le président tram
qui a tenu les promesses faites au
peuple américain
le monde n'en est que plus pacifique
aujourd'hui monsieur le président
monsieur le secrétaire général mesdames
et messieurs les représentants mesdames
et messieurs les ambassadeurs et
ambassadrices et dirigeants et
dirigeantes du monde
mon commandant en chef ont président des
états unis d'amérique
donald g trump je vous remercie
c'est pour moi un insigne honneur que de
m'adresser à l'assemblée générale de
l'organisation des nations unies 75 ans
après la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale et la création de
l'organisation des nations unies nous
livrons une fois encore un grand combat
mondial
nous livrons une bataille féroce contre
un ennemi invisible
le virus de chine qui a fait un nombre
incalculable de victimes dans 188 pays
aux etats unis nous avons lancé la
mobilisation la plus agressive
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale nous
avons rapidement produit un nombre
record de respirateurs à tel point que
nous avons pu partager notre excédent
avec des amis et des partenaires du
monde entier
nous avons été les premiers à mettre au
point des traitements permettant de
sauver des vies réduisant le taux de
mortalité de 85% depuis avril grâce à
nos efforts trois vaccins sont en phase
finale de leur essai clinique
nous sommes en train de les produire en
masse à l'avance pour qu'il puisse être
livré dès leur arrivée nous allons
distribuer un vaccin
nous allons venir à bout du virus nous
allons mettre un terme à la pandémie et
souffrir s'ouvrira à nous une nouvelle
ère de prospérité de coopération et de
fait sans précédent alors que nous
oeuvrons pour réaliser cet avenir
radieux nous devons exiger de la nation
qui est à l'origine de ce fléau mondial
qu'elle rende des comptes je veux parler
de la chine lorsque le virus est apparu
la chine a interdit les voyages à
l'intérieur du pays tout en permettant
que des vols quittent la chine est
infecte le monde
la chine a condamné l'interdiction de
voyager que j'ai imposé à son pays alors
même que annulé leurs vols intérieurs et
enfermait leurs citoyens chez eux
le gouvernement chinois et
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
est pour ainsi dire contrôlé par la
chine ont prétendu à tort qu'il
n'existait aucune preuve de transmission
entre humains
plus tard ils ont prétendu à tort que
les personnes asymptomatiques n'était
pas contagieuse les nations unies
doivent tenir la chine comptable de ses
actes en outre chaque année la chine
déversent des millions et des millions
de tonnes de plastique et de déchets
dont les océans pratique la surpêche
dans les eaux d'autres pays détruit de
vastes pans de récifs coralliens et mais
plus de mercure toxiques dans
l'atmosphère que n'importe quel autre
pays au monde les émissions de carbone
de la chine sont au moins deux fois plus
importante que celle des états unis elle
ne cesse d'augmenter à un rythme effréné
al'inverse après mon retrait de l'accord
partiel de paris sur le climat l'année
dernière l'amérique a réduit ses
émissions de carbone
plus que tout autre pays parties à
l'accord ceux qui attaquent le bilan
environnemental exceptionnel des états
unis tout en fermant les yeux sur la
pollution généralisée de la chine ne se
soucie pas de l'environnement tout ce
qu'ils veulent c'est punir l'amérique et
je ne l'accepterai jamais si
l'organisation des nations unies veut
être une organisation efficace elle doit
se concentrer sur les vrais problèmes du
monde
je veux parler notamment du terrorisme
de la répression des femmes du travail
forcé du trafic de drogue de la traite
d'êtres humains et à des fins
d'exploitation sexuelle des persécutions
religieuses et de l'épuration ethnique
des minorités religieuses
l'amérique sera toujours une figure de
proue en matière de droits humains
mon administration promeut la liberté de
religion l'eau
deux mille actions l'autonomisation des
femmes la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité la lutte contre la
traite des êtres humains et la
protection des enfants à naître
nous savons aussi la prospérité de
l'amérique est le socle de la liberté et
de la sécurité partout dans le monde
en l'espace d'à peine trois ans nous
avons bâti la plus grande économie de
l'histoire et nous sommes en train de
faire de même
une fois encore et rapidement notre
armée a vu sa taille augmenter de
manière substantielle nous avons investi
2500 milliards de dollars dans notre
armée ces quatre dernières années nous
avons l'armé la plus puissante au monde
et de loin
nous nous sommes opposés à des décennies
d'abus commerciaux de la chine nous
avons redynamisé l'alliance de l'otan ou
d'autres pays payent à présent une part
beaucoup plus juste nous avons chargé
des partenariats historiques avec le
mexique le guatemala le honduras et el
salvador pour mettre un terme au trafic
d'êtres humains
nous sommes aux côtés des papes du cuba
du nicaragua et du venezuela dans leur
juste lutte pour la liberté
nous nous sommes retirés de la corde
désastreux sur le nucléaire iranien et
avons imposé de très lourdes sanctions
au premier état au monde à soutenir le
terrorisme
nous avons réduit à néant le califat de
l'oeil elle à 100%
nous avons tué son fondateur et
dirigeant al baghdadi et nous avons
éliminé le pire terroriste au monde
qasem soleimani ce mois ci nous sommes
parvenus à un accord de paix entre la
serbie et le kosovo
nous avons enregistré une percée
décisive avec deux accords de paix au
moyen-orient après deux décennies
d'absence totale de progrès israël les
émirats arabes unis le bahreïn ont tous
trois signé un accord de paix historique
à la maison blanche et de nombreux
autres pays du moyen-orient où les
rejoindre ils nous rejoignent rapidement
et ils savent que c'est formidable pour
eux que c'est formidable pour le monde
entier
ces accords de paix révolutionnaires
sont l'aube d'un nouveau moyen-orient
en optant une approche pour une app
store approche différente nous sommes
parvenus à des résultats différents des
résultats bien meilleurs
nous avons opté pour une approche et
cette approche a fonctionné nous avons
l'intention de produire d'autres accords
de paix sous peu et je n'ai jamais été
plus optimiste en ce qui concerne
l'avenir de la région
il n'y a pas de sens dans le sable il
faut espérer que cette époque soit
révolu alors que nous parlons les
etats-unis travaillent aussi à mettre un
terme à la guerre en afghanistan et nous
ramenons nos soldats à la maison
l'amérique réalise son destin d'artisans
de paix mais c'est une paix qui repose
sur la force nous n'avons jamais été
plus fort nous n'avons jamais eu d'armes
aussi sophistiquée et franchement jamais
nous n'aurions ne serait-ce qu imaginé
en avoir de semblable et je prie dieu
que nous n'ayons jamais à nous en servir
pendant des décennies les mêmes voix
lasse nous ont proposé les mêmes
solutions défaillante s'efforçant de
réaliser des ambitions mondiales aux
dépens de leur propre peuple
or ce n'est que lorsque vous vous
souciez de vos propres citoyens que vous
jetez réellement des bases pour la
coopération en tant que président j'ai
rejeté les approches malheureuse du
passé et c'est avec fierté que je fais
passer l'amérique avant tout tout comme
vous devriez faire passer vos pays avant
tout c'est bien c'est ce que vous
devriez faire je suis on ne peut plus
confiant je sais que l'année prochaine
lorsque nous nous réunirons en personne
nous vivrons une des plus grandes années
de notre histoire et franchement il faut
espérer de l'histoire du monde
je vous remercie dieu vous bénisse tous
dieu bénisse l'amérique et dieu bénisse
les nations unies on met en bus au nom
de l'assemblée générale je remercie le
président des états unis d'amérique pour
son allocution
je donne maintenant la parole au
représentant de la turquie qui va
présenter une allocution du chef d'état